طبعا تاريخيا معروف يعني الايرانيين
تاريخيا عجزوا حتى الرسول محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم ويحمل رساله اسلاميه رساله
سماويه
فتاريخيا يعني كل واحد قال التاريخ العربي
الفارسي او تاريخ الفارسي يعرف انه ايران
صاحبه اطماع فكان ياكد دائما انه ايران
يعني قد ما ننطيها او نتنازلها تبقى
صاحبتها اطماع والدليل انه المعاهده 74
اعطانا نصف شط العرب
اتفاقيه الجزائر وبقت تريد اكثر ايران
لديها اطماع وايران الثوره ما يسمى بثوره
الاسلاميه هي ضد العالم العربي بالاساس
ولا يعني العالم العربي هو هم العرب ماده
الاسلام فكيف ايران صدر الاسلام
من هذا القبيل
عن وفاه الخميني ماذا قال
عن وفاه الخميني قال اني يعني قاعد اتهيا
حتى اروح يعني للمكتبي
فدخل عليه احد الحراس الشخصيين المرافقين
ضابط برتبه عقيد وكان فرح فقالي الخميني
توفى قال نهرت هذا الضابط يعني مرت على
الصرفه وقلت له الله يرحمه يعني للخميني
انه احنا ما نحقد مثلهم
لا نحقد يعني ولا نتشافى ولا بالمرض طيب
بخصوص الاطماع الايرانيه كان العراق على
ايام نظام صدام حسين سلم ايران نفسها اللي
قتلها ثمان سنوات
طائرات عراقيه
ومن ثم يبدو انه صدام حسين الرئيس العراقي
الراحل صدم
بتصرفاتها لاحقا ايضا هناك ما نقله لك في
هذا السياق
كانت زياره لاحد المسؤولين العراقيين الى
ايران
وكانت ايران قد هيات يعني
هيئه اجواء طيبه ظاهريا لكن كانت تخفي
نواياها الخبيثه
ورحبت انه العراق اذا يعني قالت لهذا
المسؤول انه العراق اذا يريد يعني
[موسيقى]
ما معناه يودع اي شيء يعني داخل ايران
فاحنا على الرحب والسعه
وعمليه خديعه هي كانت
عند ما نقل الموضوع للقياده يعني صار
القرار انه ايداع هاي الطائرات طبعا هو
كان خطا استراتيجي
لكن الخطا يعني محسوب من خلال نوايا
الطيبه يعني النوايا طيبه القياده
العراقيه والعراقيين وايران يعني بخديعتها
ومكرهه
استطاعت ان توظف هذا الموضوع ماذا قال عن
هذه النقطه تحديدا يعني كان ما مستغرب انه
ايران هو هذا قدرها